in bikini Faso there has been heavy
gunfire overnight in the capital
wagadugu the military is on the ground
and has taken control of major streets
and other strategic installations
television and radio signals are down
for more on this story let's bring in
Nicholas hark who joins us via Skype
from Saint Louis a town just north of
Dakar in Senegal and Nick what more do
we know about this attack
well residents that we spoke to told me
that they were stunned they were woken
up by gunfire in the middle of the night
around three o'clock in the capital of
wagadugu heavy gunfire and right now
just moments ago we heard reports of a
loud explosion just outside the
presidential Palace that's kosyam in the
wealthy suburbs of wagadugu now the head
of state uh Colonel demeba that took
over power in January while we haven't
heard from him there hasn't been any
official announcement and there's a
feeling of confusion confusion among
many people in wagarugu of who's behind
this and what are their motivations now
there's also one resident told me a
feeling of what he said Deja Vu of
course in January we saw the same mode
of operandi where we saw the military
takeover strategic locations in the
capital the parliament the presidential
Palace the streets the the the the radio
and television station and that was when
damiba took over in a coup in January so
far there's still no announcement made
of why there's doing this but there's
been Mountain greases amongst the ranks
of the military ever since there was
been a step up of attacks from armed
groups linked to Al-Qaeda and isil Emily
Nick what led up to this deadly incident
I mean only yesterday there were
protests in the streets about the city
situation in Burkina Faso tell us a
little bit more about the leader
tables
well yes when demeba took power in
January he made one pledge to try to
bring back security for people in
Burkina Faso because of the UPS uptake
on in terms of the number of attacks
there's been millions of people
displaced just this year alone except
that since he's taken over power there's
been even more attacks just a few days
ago like you mentioned there was a
protest but on the heels of that there
was a convoy of several members of the
military that were killed now officially
the the government said that only 11
people were killed some people that we
spoke to uh in the ranks of the military
said there were many more uh that died
and that the they were accusing the
government of covering up information
there's a sense that those that are on
the front line in the North in the west
where there are attacks from group
linked to Al-Qaeda and isil are
disconnected from their higher ranking
officers that are in wagadugu and and
that disconnect is leading to resentment
amongst the ranks of the military
because the Reba came with this promise
to bring back peace and security except
it's really gotten worse and there's
more division is also there's this
feeling that uh the media has really
focused on trying to bring back the old
Garden what I'm alluding here to is the
former president bless compare remember
Emily in 2014 he was deposed into
popular Uprising we've seen key figure
of his regime uh specifically members of
the military take up senior ranks in the
mebas government but now for the moment
what people are wanting to know is who's
in charge of the country and who is
behind who who is ordering these
soldiers on the streets of wagadugu so
there's a lot of confusions confusion
who's who's in charge and people hoping
that we'll get some clarification in the
hours to come Emily I have valid
questions to ask thank you very much for
the update as always and Nicholas Hawk
live for us just north of Dakar in
Senegal thank you